retour en france ce matin claude allègre
présentait au monde enseignant réunis à
la cité des sciences de la villette sa
charte pour l'école du 21e siècle on
connaissait déjà la philosophie de ce
grand projet sur le devenir de l'école
primaire désormais le ministre de
l'éducation et entrer dans les détails
et la nuque jean-pierre pasteur c'est
devant un parterre de personnalités
politiques droite et gauche confondues
les maires de grandes villes les
représentants des enseignants et des
parents d'élèves que claude allègre a
lancé ce matin officiellement sa charte
pour l'école du 21e siècle le débat
était retransmis en direct dans toutes
les académies de france un baptême en
grande pompe pour un projet ambitieux
une modernisation de notre système
éducatif une adaptation à ce que sont
les enfants d'aujourd'hui et en même
temps se recentrer sur ce qui est la
base autres écoles la base de notre
formation initiale par les lire écrire
compter les programmes seront recentrées
sur les apprentissages fondamentaux les
rythmes scolaires seront aménagés afin
d'intégrer l'initiation aux nouvelles
technologies à la culture aux arts aux
sports et aux langues enfin le rôle de
l'instituteur sera redéfinie chef d'une
équipe éducative
il devra également apporter une aide
personnalisée aux élèves en difficulté
nous ce qui nous intéresse équipe au
statu quo à l'école et qu'on réponde
aujourd'hui enfin aux enfants en
difficulté donc on va profiter de ce
débat qui autour de l'achat procès de
faire avancer les idées aujourd'hui a
besoin de plus d'école pour les enfants
que pour entrer dans le 21e siècle
justement on peut pas laisser des
enfants soleil sur le côté la question
du temps la question de la formation des
enseignants sont des questions centrales
auxquelles pour l'instant le ministre
n'a pas répondu
la charte de l'école du 21e siècle se
mettra progressivement en place dès le
mois prochain elle sera expérimenté dans
deux mille écoles avant de se
généraliser
bonne chance
à paris dans lequel